think do you think you could be married
to a rich man and know he has a mistress
or two knives that are better looking
than you no you know you'd get pregnant
of the kids and then there would be the
mistress I couldn't be with a guy
knowing that he's sleeping with someone
else really yeah but I mean if it was
like you're an only fan I mean yeah
isn't that a little yeah but I suppose
yeah no no you are right you are right
but I I don't know like I mean if it was
like an old guy with like wrinkles and
stuff I feel like maybe yeah like I
wouldn't mind if we had a few girls like
if he was willing to pay my rent and
paying for my car and stop paying for me
to drive